[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون
كيري ان تقرير الاستخبارات الامريكيه يحمل
بقدر عال من الثقه النظام السوري مسؤوليه
الهجوم الكيماوي في في دمشق واضاف كيري ان
اي تدخل عسكري ضد الاسد سيكون بمثابه
رساله الى ايران وحزب الله اللبناني نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين كيف
تبدو احتمالات القيام بعمل عسكري ضد نظام
الاسد في ضوء ما كشفه تقييم الاستخبارات
الامريكي والى اي حد يمكن ان يؤثر نشر هذا
التقييم على جهود واشنطن لبناء تحالف دولي
ضد نظام
[موسيقى]
الاسد اذا قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي جون
كيري ان تقييما اجرته الاستخبارات
الامريكيه استبعد ان تكون المعارضه
السوريه وراء هجوم الحادي من اب اغسطس على
ريف دمشق ووصف كيري الهجوم بانه جريمه ضد
الانسانيه وقال ان بشار الاسد قاتل تجب
محاسبته واضاف كيري ان الولايات المتحده
تستند الى ادله من مصادر عده لتحميل دمشق
المسؤوليه عن الهجوم الكيماوي ولن تكرر
اخطاء
العراق ادعوكم لقراءه الحكم الذي توصلت
اليه استخبارات حول الهجوم بالسلاح
الكيميائي الذي قام به نظام الاسد ضد
المعارضه والاحياء التي تسيطر عليها
المعارضه او تنازع السيطره عليها في ضواحي
دمشق استخباراتها قيمت بعنايه واعادت
تقييم المعلومات بخصوص ذلك
واقول لكم اننا فعلنا ذلك باهتمام اكبر
مما كان في التجربه العراقيه ولن نسمح
بتكرار ذلك
[تصفيق]
الحدث بفارق 13 صوتا فقط في تصويت مجلس
العموم البريطاني لندن لن تشارك في اي عمل
عسكري محتمل ضد سوريا خسر رئيس الوزراء
ديفيد كامرون التصويت وخسرت واشنطن حليفها
الاول ورحله البحث السري عن حلفاء اخرين
مستمره يقول وزير الدفاع الامريكي جاك
هيجل منهجنا هو مواصله حجد تحالف دولي
يتحرك بشكل جماعي واعتقد انكم ترون ان
عددا من الدول تعلن موقفها من استخدام
الاسلحه الكيميائيه سنواصل مشاورات مع
حلفائنا وشركائنا واصدقائنا في هذا الصدد
فرنسا هي الحليف المعلن للضربه العسكريه
المحتمله الى جانب تركيا اما بالنسبه
للعرب فيبدو ان الراغبين في ذلك لم يحسموا
امرهم بعد او ربما ينتظرون اللحظه الاخيره
لاعلان مشاركتهم في العمليه توقع الرئيس
الفرنسي فرانسوا اولوند في مقابله مع
صحيفه لوموند ان تحدث الضربه العسكريه قبل
الاربعاء المقبل ضربه على الارجح لن تكون
تحت غطاء الامم المتحده بسبب الرفض الروسي
الصيني المعهود بشان سوريا اوروبيا برلين
لم ولن تفكر في دعم اي عسكري ضد
دمشق لم نتلقى اي طلب بشان تحرك عسكري
ايضا الحكومه الالمانيه لم تفكر مطلقا في
تحرك عسكري ضد سوريا وكما تعلمون دستورنا
وضع قيودا على ذلك يد الحكومه التركيه
طليقه للتحرك الهادف الى معاقبه نظام
الاسد وليس اسقاطه كما تامل المعارضه
السوريه القليل المعروف عن الخطه العسكريه
انها ستكون سرعه وجو ودون قوه بريه تركيا
ستعتمد اساسا على قاعدتي انجرليك وازمير
العسكريتين وكما في الاردن ولبنان والعراق
مخيمات اللاجئين في تركيا تستقبل اكثر مما
تستطيع تحمله وبمدرسة
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه جورج
ميسون ومن باريس الدكتور خطار ابو دياب
الباحث في المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الجيوسياسيه دكتور خطار ابو دياب اذا
فرنسا فقط ستكون في الواجهه بما ان في في
موقف الالماني الموقف البريطاني موقف
البلجيكي ماذا تتوقع بالنسبه
لل التحالف الدولي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده لشن هذه
الضربه نعم فرنسا حسمت امرها منذ فتره على
خطه الثنائي ساركوزي جوبيه الثنائي هولاند
فابيوس يقوم بنفس السياسه باتجاه سوريا
وهو الذي كان يطالب الولايات المتحده
بالمزيد من الحزم في سابقه من نوعها هذه
المره ستكون باريس الحليف الاول لواشنطن
بدل لندن بالطبع الدول الاخرى مهمه جدا
لكنها عاده لا تشترك في العمليات اخر الا
اخبار تشير الى ان الدنمارك ستساهم ربما
في العمليات في مطلق الاحوال هناك اتكال
على دعم سياسي واسع لضربه محدوده في
الزمان والمكان هذا التحالف اذا عماده
الاساسي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بامكان واشنطن من الناحيه التقنيه
والعسكريه القيام بالعمليه لوحدها لكن من
الناحيه الرمزيه هذا التحالف الواسع مهم
جدا سيشمل ايضا تركيا ربما عده دول عربيه
ايضا الاهم من كل ذلك ان وقت
اي عدم العقاب انتهى بالنسبه للنظام
السوري طال الزمان لانه بعد سقوط اكثر من
120,000 قتيل ارتكب النظام الخطا الاضافي
الكبير الذي لا يغفر وفي هذا كان هناك
تحدي للمجموعه الدوليه ربما تحدي شخصي
للرئيس اوباما الذي تكلم مرارا عن خطوط
الحمر وهكذا هناك عد تنازلي بال فعل كما
قلتم في تقريركم سيبدا اعتبارا من
الغد سيد كاتس ضيفي من واشنطن هل م قاله
كيري وما شرحه عن تقييم تقرير
الاستخباراتي الامريكي حول استخدام النظام
السوري لاسلحه كيماويه كافيا ومقنعا
وقانونيا بما يكفي لشن الضربه على النظام
السوري اعتقد ان واقع ان البيت الابيض قد
كشف عن هذا التقرير يعني ان الضربه اتيه
لا محاله لا اعرف ولا اتوقع ان ينشروا هذا
التقرير من دون ان يضربوا ف في التقرير
وضوح لجهه ما قامت به الحكومه السوريه ضد
شعبها واعتقد ان البيت الابيض او اداره
اوباما طبعا لا تريد التدخل وهي لا تريد
هذا التدخل لكن اداره اوباما اطلقت و نشرت
هذا التقرير بالتالي في ذلك مؤشر على انهم
فعلا سوف يطلقوا هذه الضربه ولكن ما هو
المستند القانوني لاطلاق هذه الضربه هل هو
مجرد تقرير استخباراتي بالنظر الى
التقارير الاستخباراتيه التي كانت كلها
مخطئه وخاطئه فيما حدث في العراق الان هذا
التقرير ما الذي يضمن انه دقيق ويمكن
التعويل عليه وبالتالي شن ضربه بدون
الرجوع الى مجلس الامن وفقا لاتفاقيه حظر
الاسلحه الكيماويه
تعرفون اعتقد اننا شهدنا حالات سابقه في
الماضي القريب قامت بها الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها باستخدام القوه من دون موافقه
مجلس الامن لان في مجلس الامن ثمت حكومتان
اعني بذلك الصين وروسيا وكلاهما سوف تعرقل
اي جهود وفعلا لا ت بهان على ما يبدو بحجم
الارواح التي تزهق في هذا البلد بالتالي
اعتقد ان ثمه معيار في الغرب قد ظهر وهو
اسم مسؤوليه الحمايه والمسؤوليه من اجل
الحمايه كثر قد سقطوا في سوريا ولم نتحرك
في السابق لكن استخدام الاسلحه الكيماويه
هو فعلا شيء شائن جدا ولا يمكن لولايات
المتحده الا ان تتحرك لان ذلك اذا ما لم
تتحرك يعني ان ذلك مشين ويمكن للاسد ان
يكرر ذلك مرارا وتكرارا ويمكن ان يحدو
اخرون حدوه ايضا وثمه هواجس اخرى مرتبطه
ربما بالشرعيه هذه اصوات نسمعها هنا
وهناك وبان هذا النوع من السلوك ربما كان
يتطلب عقوبه قاسيه للغايه والا نحن نفتح
الباب واسعا امام اي طرف للقيام بالامر
عينه ولكن بشكل سريع سيد كاتس هنالك تقرير
نشرته الفورين بوليسي يقول ان الولايات
المحده ساعدت صدام لقصف حلبجه بالاسلحه
الكيماويه الان تظهر الاخلاق الامريكيه من
تقنع انا لا اعرف اي شيء عن دقه هذا
التقرير في الفورين
بولسي ولا ولا اعتق اعتقد في الواقع ان
المنطق ضعيف في جدا انا اتذكر تماما خلال
الحرب بين العراق وايران ان الخوف في الغ
الغرب وفي العالم العربي بالخليج في بشكل
خاص بان تربح ايران هذه الحرب وكان الجميع
جاهزا للقيام باي شيء اتذكر زيارتي لبلدان
الخليج في الثمانيات وكانوا فعلا يخشون
نصرا ايرانيا هل ان صدام حسين استشار
الولايات المتحده عند استخدامه للاسلحه
الكيمياويه ضد شعب لا اعتقد ذلك بالتالي
فعلا انا
اشكك اميل الى التشكيك في هذا النوع من
التقارير وعلي ان اطرح السؤال لماذا يظهر
التقرير في هذا التوقيت
تحديدا تماما بعد ان قام السوريون بذلك هل
انه يحاول ان يقول انه بما ان الامر كان
مقبولا بالنسبه للصدام فهذا مقبول بالنسبه
للاسد اعتقد ان هذا فعلا مريب ا طيب تشكك
ولكن تقارير قديمه تتحدث عن ذلك باي حال
ليس موضوعنا فقط يعني كشار للموضوع بما
انه يجري التحدث عن الاخلاق هنا دكتور
دكتور خطار بريطانيا مجلس العموم رفض
المانيا لن تشارك بلجيكا ترفض بولندا كذلك
عتى كانت تتبع الولايات المتحده الان
هنالك موقف
مختلف بالدول العربيه تونس اعلنت قبل قليل
انها ضد التدخل العسكري الخارجي في سوريا
مصر موقفها واضح ايضا عن اي ضربه هنا
نتحدث من الناحيه القانونيه والاخلاقيه ضد
بلد
عربي اولا بالنسبه بالنسبه للمصوغات
الشرعيه الرئيس الفرنسي ركز على حق
الحمايه ومسؤوليه الحمايه وهناك قرار صدر
من الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في العام
2005 بهذا الخصوص عندما تحتجز روسيا
والصين مجلس الامن وتمارس حق النقض الفيتو
ثلاث مرات خلال تسعه اشهر في الموضوع
السوري ويكون كل هذا التعطيل الان بعد
الضربه الكيميائيه هناك مساله اضافيه هناك
بروتوكول العام
1925 اي المعاهده لحظر الاسلحه الكيميائيه
وهي تحرم استخدام هذه الاسلحه على نطاق
واسع اذا هناك مسوغات قانونيه ليس هناك من
استهداف لبلد لانه عربي او غير عربي
المساله واضحه اعتقد
ان الدول التي تحاول الان تبرير
تقاعسها عندها مشكله في صدقيتها عند هناك
مشكله اصلا في الزعامه العالميه وفي
الحوكه لا يمكن ترك هذه هذا العالم غابه
يسمح فيه لنظام بان يقوم بقتل شعبه بهذه
الطريقه واظن ان الاهم هو وجود تحالف
اراضي من اجل القول بان هذا ممنوع وبانه
يجب وضع حد له بالطبع لسنا في مجال
المقارنه مع العراق ليست هي حرب ليس هذا
هو تدخل عسكري الكل يتكلم عن ضربه محدوده
في الزمان والمكان هي اقرب للضربه
العقابيه هي رساله هي رساله للنظام رساله
لروسيا من اجل تسهيل الحل السياسي لاحقا
وليس من اجل اسقاط النظام كما تكلم اليوم
الرئيس الفرنسي فرانسوا هولاند اها واصلا
يعني تردد كثيرا هذا الكلام عن انها ضربه
محدوده وكررها اليوم جون كيري وهنالك
تركيز على انه ليس لاسقاط النظام الاسد
سيد كاتس اشرح لي لو سمحت كيف يعني ضربه
محدوده ماذا ستكون نتائجها اذا كان الاسد
لن يسقط
اذا سوف يستمر سوف يستمر في
موقعه وبالتالي الاشتباكات والنزاع الداخل
في سوريا ستستمر وحرب
استنزاف عفوا سوف نضطر سيد كاس اسمح ليال
الرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما يدلي بكلمه
حسب كلمه مسجله اذا والقاها بعد محادثاته
مع بعض قاده دول البلطيق لنستمع سويا
واعود اليكم
اذا سوف نتابع هذه الكلمه فور جهزها وهي
كلمه للرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما سيد
كات كنت قد سالتك عن الاهداف المرجوه من
هذه الضربه المحدوده اسالك اذا كانت ضربه
محدوده اذا الاسد يبقى في منصبه المعارضه
تبقى في الداخل تحارب ماذا ماذا
استفدنا
هذا سؤال وجيه في الواقع قبل بضعه ايام
نشرت مقالا قلت فيه تماما ان هذه الضربه
يجب ان تكون محدوده لكن محدوده على الاسد
بنفسه اي اي ضربه سوف يكون لها معنى هي
الضربه التي سوف تكسر هذا النظام لتغير
سلوكه ولكن على ما يبدو البيت الابيض لا
يسمع ل نصائحي وبالتالي سوف يخطط لهذه
الضربه المحدوده لا اعتقد ان سوف تكون
محدوده بمعنى الكلمه اعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده سوف تنتهزها فرصه لكي تدمر الى
اكبر قدر ممكن القوات العسكريه السوريه
الدفاعات الجويه كذلك المنشات في المرافئ
وما شبه بالتالي هذه الضربه سوف تقود قدره
النظام السوري على مقاتله المعارضه واعتقد
ايضا ان الحكومه السوريه سوف تكون في وضع
صعب للغايه لانها لن تتمتع
بالقوات التقليديه لكي تقوم بما تنويه اذا
ما استعانت بالاسلحه الكيمياويه مره اخرى
فسوف تضرب الولايات المتحده مره اخرى
بمعنى اخر اعتقد انهم فتحوا الباب فعلا
واعتقد انهم سوف يصابون باذن كبير فعلا
ايضا شكرا لك ضيفي الكريم من واشنطن وايضا
ضيفنا من باريس ابقوا معنا لو سمحتم لاننا
سنناقش بقيه هذا الموضوع بعد فاصل قصير
فابقوا
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد والى كلمه الرئيس
الامريكي براك
اوباما استخدام الاسلحه الكيمياويه في
المستقبل ووصول هذه الاسلحه الى ارهابيين
يمكن ان يستخدموها ضدنا بالتالي قلت في
السابق وعنيت ما
اقوله ان العالم عنده واجب وهو ان نحرص
على ان نحترم هذا المعيار بعدم استخدام
الاسلحه الكيماويه انا لم اتخذ القرار بعد
لجهه الخطوات التي يمكن ان تؤخذ لتعزيز
هذا المعيار لكن كما قلت في
السابق القوات العسكريه
والفريق العامل ينظران بمجموعه من
الخيارات واستشر ايضا حلفاء لنا مع كونجرس
مشاورات دائره ايضا مع كل الجهات
المعنيه وفي اي من الحياه نحن لا نفكر في
تحرك عسكري يشارك تشارك فيه القوات البريه
او ايضا حمله طويله الامد لكن نحن ننظر في
احتمال عمليه محدوده ضيقه من شانها ان
تساعده على ان نحرص ان لا سوريين فحسب كل
من في العالم اذا ان يفهم هؤلاء ان
المجتمع الدولي يهتم للحفاظ على حظر
الاسلحه الكيمياويه وهذا المعيار اذا مره
اخرى اكرر نحن لا نفكر
باي التزام طويل الامد لا نفكر باي مقاربه
تشمل قوات بريه في الميدان لكن نفكر في
خيارات تقتصر على لواجه المتصله بالاسلحه
الكيماويه ونفهم ان الحل لن يكون عسكريا
في هذا النزاع وفي هذه الماساه التي
تشهدها
سوريا وسوف اتابع التشاور بشكل وثيق مع
الكونجرس الى جانب الكشف عن هذه التقارير
غير السريه لدينا تقارير سريات توفر لعضاء
الكونجرس وهذه اذا معلومات سريه لاعضاء
الكونجرس كما قلت والى الشركاء الدوليين
وسوف استمر في اعلام الشعب الامريكي فيما
تصلنا معلومات اضافيه وعلى هذا الاساس اود
ان رحب بالرئيس الفس
وبرئيس سكشن وكذلك الرئيس بريتش الى البيت
الابيض هذه
البلدان عندها علاقات وثيقه جدا مع
الولايات المتحده هي بلدان حليفه وبسبب
هذه العلاقات الاستثنائيه مع هذه البلدان
اود اذا كان هذا
الجزء الذي تحدث فيه الرئيس الامريكي
باراك اوباما عن خططه بالنسبه لضربه ضد
النظام سوري عقابا له على استخدام الاسلحه
الكيماويه تقريبا كرر ما قاله وزير
خارجيته جون كيري عن انها ستكون ضربه
محدوده ضيقه لنيت اطلاقا كررها مرتين ل
نيه اطلاقا للتورط في حرب طويله الامد او
بادخال جنود بريا يعني الى داخل سوريا
وبان كل ما يريده من هذه الضربه المحدوده
هو افهام ليس فقط السوريين وانما العالم
اجمع بان استخدام الاسلحه الكيماويه خط
احمر لا يمكن ان يتكرر بوجود الم المجتمع
الدولي الحريص على هذه المساله وايضا لفت
الى ان هو يعلم جيدا بان الحل في في نزاع
كالذي يحدث في سوريا لن يكون عسكريا وانما
سياسيا وانه سيتابع التشاور ولفت الى وجود
تقارير غير سريه نشرت امام الكونغرس وايضا
تقارير استخباراتيه سريه وكلما علم بشيء
جديد سوف يطلع الراي العام الامريكي
الداخلي عليها وسوف يطلع حلفائه سمى
اسرائيل الاردن وتركيا بخصوص هذه الضربه
المحدوده اذا ضيفي الكريمين من باريس
وواشنطن سيد كاتس بناء على ما قاله
اوباما اذا الضربه اكيده حتى اللحظه هل
يمكن ان نتكهن متى
تقريبا اعتقد فعلا انها وشيكه اعتقد انها
سوف تكون خلال الايام القليله المقبله
بحسب راي نعم انا كنت اتوقع انها سوف
نشهدها في الاسبوع القادم لكن لعلها سوف
تكون في بدايه الاسبوع المقبل وسوف تحصل
حتما دكتور خطار ما
رايك نعم انا رايي انه بعد عوده المفتشين
وقبل قمه العشرين في روسيا في الخامس من
هذا الشهر هناك نافذه لحصول هذه العمليه
اذا اعتبارا من يوم غد ليس بيوم غد بالضبط
اعتبارا من يوم الاحد تفتح هذه النافذه
خلال الايام القادمه القليله القادمه
دكتور خطار هو قال الحل انن يكون عسكريا
في سوريا هل يقصد بان هذه الضربه المحدوده
ستؤدي الى دفع الاسد للتنازل والقبول
بحضور جناف اثنين والتنحي وفقا لحل يكون
قريب من الحل
اليمني نعم هناك عمل امريكي اوروبي دؤوب
على انتاج الحل السياسي في سوريا بالامس
عندما كان رئيس الائتلاف الوطني السوري
لقوى الثوره والمعارضه في الاليزيه ابلغ
من الرئيس هولند ضروره تهيئه الائتلاف
ليكون البديل السياسي والمحاور السياسي
للنظام في ان معا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ابلغت ايضا الائتلاف ضروره
الاستعداد لمؤتمر جنب اثنين العله الكبرى
في الموضوع هو الغموض غير البناء في
النصوص التي اتفق عليها في جنيف واحد
وجنيف اثنين وايضا الاصرار الروسي على
بقاء الرئيس السوري اظن انه من وراء هذه
العمليه حول الكيميائي هناك رساله توجهها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى روسيا كي
تسهم في الحل السياسي واظن ان من اولى
علامات الحل السياسي عدم ترشيح بشار الاسد
نفسه لولايه جديده في ربيع العام 2014
وبدء الحل السياسي عبر تشكيل حكومه من
عناصر من النظام ومن المعارضه في ان معا
كما تفكر واشنطن طيب سيد كاتس اريد ان
اسالك عن مسالتين مهمتين جدا
بالنسبه ل يعني هذا التقرير الاستخباراتي
الامريكي الذي اتكل عليه ان كان كيري او
اوباما طيب
يقول التقرير العناصر الاستخباراتيه التي
استخدمت للخروج بهذه الخلاصات تتضمن
معلومات حول التحضيرات لهذا الهجوم
الكيماوي الذي حدث طيب اذا كانوا يعرفون
الامريكيون ومخابرات بان هنالك حضرات
لهكذا هجوم الم يكن بالامكان اطلاق تحذير
يعني وقتها ربما التهديد بضربه كيف نفهم
ذلك لا يمكن ان اشرح في الواقع لانه ليس
لدي ادنى فكره لجهه الوقت الذي استغرقته
كل هذه العمليه هذا صعب للغايه ما يمكنن
قوله هو ان تقرير يشير الى ان البيت
الابيض مقتنع اقتناعا تاما بان الحكومه
السوريه هي التي استخدمت الاسلحه
الكيماويه هم مقتنعون بذلك يصدقونه وسوف
يتصرفون على هذا الاساس طيب سيد كاتس ايضا
السؤال الثاني الذي كنت اود ان اسالك عنه
هو مساله حمايه المدنيين في اثناء هكذا
ضربه ماذا لو عمد النظام السوري الى وضع
دروع بشريه في بنك الاهداف الذي تنوي
بلادك
ضربها
اعتقد ان تكون في هذه الحاله مسؤوليه
الحكومه السوريه اذا ما تعرض هؤلاء لاي
اذى لا لعلهم سوف يحاولون القيام بشيء من
هذا القبيل ولكن من سوف يذهب الى هذه
الاهداف ربما مناصريه لكن لا اعتقد ان ذلك
من شانه ان يعرقل اي تحرك امريكي دكتور
خطار اعرف ان يعني في في القصص العسكريه
ربما نحتاج الى خبير ولكن من الناحيه
السياسيه هل يمكن اتخاذ قرار نتيجته تكون
يعني قرار سياسي نتيجته عسكريه ب
مثلا تواصل حظر جوي على سوريا اقامه مناطق
مثلا تحمي اللاجئين المدنيين ام فقط ضربه
وتتبخر بعدها واشنطن و يعني تستمر الامور
على ما كانت عليه مع اسد اكثر
ضعفا بالنسبه لمساله الدروع البشريه
النظام يهو
بوضع المعتقلين والمفقودين دروعا بشريه
لتفادي الضربات اذا فعلها في الماضي صدام
حسين هدد كذلك ولم يفعل كل هذا من باب
التهويل من ناحيه اخرى بالنسبه ل لمواضيع
الضربه العسكريه وفعاليتها اذا دمرت وسائل
الدفاع الجوي وسلاح الجو ستفرض مناطق
الحضر الجوي بشكل تلقائي اشك في ذلك لا
اظن ان الع عمليه ستكون موسعه الى هذا
الحد لكن هناك مسؤوليه تجاه بلدان مثل
تركيا ومثل لبنان ومثل الاردن اذا بدات
واشنطن بالعمليه وحصلت ردود فعل ستتوسع
العمليه هذا طبيعي اظن ان نظام الاسد
باقتراف الاثم الكيماوي جلب الدب الى كرمه
هو فكر انه محصن من روسيا من ايران ربما
ايضا لان اس شكرا لك دكتور خطار للاسف
انتهى وقت حلقتنا شكرا لك دكتور خط ابو
ديب الباحث في المعهد الدولي لدراسات
الجيوسياسيه كنت معنا من باريس ومن واشنطن
اشكر مارك كاتس استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه جورج ميسون واشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده في
م وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه